GOALS GOERS, JACK HUGHES.
FOR THE NEW YORK ISLANDERS,
THEY WANT TO F
THEY JUST GOT A LITTLE SCARED.
IT GOT A LITTLE HOT AND FLORIDA
IS A HECEC- THE
DEVILS TAKE CARE O O DOORSTEP.
>> THEY ARE QUICK ON THAT
TRANSITION.
>> YES, THEY PULLS UP.
THE DEFENSEMAN MISSES.
THAT WAS NICE.
THEY GET RID OF THE OFGOOD TRAF-
GABRIEL PAGEAU  TO GET PRESSURE
EXTRA
PROTECTIONAS A HAT
GAME.
OUR AT&T 5G NET COME AND IT'S A
BEAUTY.
I WAS WOKEN AND STEPS
>> NICO HISCHIER'S REACTION
AFTER THE  SMOTHER THAT AFTER T
>>'S FIRST SHIFT OF THE SECOND
PERIOD WAS ALSO REALLY
YOUR RIGHT.
>> HERE'S JOHNSSON . HISLEFT AN
I THINK  UP FOR PALMERI.
CIRCLES, HE SCORES.
KYT SHOT.
THAT'S A GOAL SCORER'S SHOT
RIGHT THERE, JENNIFER.
HE GOT A LOT ON IT.
>> JUST A TOUCH TO CLEAN IT UP
HAMILTON WITH A BLAST.
GREEN WITH THE BAR
AND IN.
THE KID THAT'S PAID THE PRICE
ALL GAME LONG GETSTSFINAL  HIS
EXTENDS, NOW HE'S GOT